people who say something that's somewhat
of a lie I want you to believe something
that's not true that it's you just
imagine them coming in hot in the house
they Park up to the garage and then you
don't respond
and they wait and go oh wait he's
he's not buying it
I'm gonna actually put this in Reverse
of the street yeah yeah actually because
they can't take that silence yeah they
can't take that side I learned um doing
student conduct all those years I knew
that by walking in my office every fight
or flight mechanism that human had was
set and so I used to always walk them
through everything and then I would
always end it with you got 24 hours from
this point
you had 24 hours to come back and say
Here's what actually happened here's my
role in it and I'm gonna count it as
though it happened here because my end
goal was I was trying to teach students
how to become
functional adults yeah and had a feel
fighter flight and still tell the truth
anyway how to feel like ah yeah yeah and
then hang in there in the moment